قتلت مستوطنتان واصيبت ثالثه بجروح في
هجوم بغور الاردن بعد قصف اسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه وجنوب لبنان ردت عليه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه وقد امر رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي بالتعبئه مع التركيز على
الدفاع الجوي والطيران بينما طالب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو سكان
غلاف غزه بالاستعداد لما سماها اياما صعبه
وشيكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى قدره الهدوء
الحذر الذي يسود جبهات المواجهه بين
اسرائيل والمقاومه على الصمود وما الذي
حققه الطرفان من جوله التصعيد الاخيره ما
هي الاعتبارات التي تحكم رؤيه نتنياهو
وحكومته في هذه المرحله وما هي حسابات
المقاومه ونظرتها الى المتغيرات في
المنطقه وما الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه
واشنطن فاحتواء التصعيد بالمنطقه في ضوء
مطالبه نتنياهو سكان محيط غزه بالاستعداد
لايام صعبه وشركه
[موسيقى]
في سياق تصعيدا فرضته اسرائيل على المنطقه
منذ عده اشهر وبعد قصف اسرائيليا على قطاع
غزه وجنوب لبنان ردت عليه فصائل المقاومه
من غزه قتلت مستوطنه واصيبت ثالثه بجروح
خطيره في هجوم بغور الاردن نفذه مسلحون
تمكنوا من الانسحاب بحسب تعبير الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقد اعلن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء
الاسرائيليه ان اجتماعات امنيه لتقييم
الموقف سيعقدها رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتانياهو ووزير الدفاع يؤف جاليند الذي
دعا الى تعزيز قوات الجيش في الضفه
الغربيه وابقاء قوات الجيش في حاله تاهب
على الجبهتين مع غزه ولبنان
جبهته غزه ولبنان تعيشان منذ صباح الجمعه
هدوءا حذرا تخلله اعلان اسرائيل اسقاط
مسيره قالت ان حزب الله اللبناني اطلقها
باتجاهها هدوء ياتي بعد قصف اسرائيليا على
قطاع غزه ولبنان استدعى ردا من فصائل
المقاومه في غزه بصواريخ قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان القبه الحديديه اعترضت 29
منها وان 14 منها سقطت في مناطق غير
ماهوله بينما سقط صاروخ واحد على منزل في
سديروت في محيط غزه الذي طالب نتنياهو
سكانه بالاستعداد لما سماها اياما صعبه
وشيكا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في الجزء الاول
من هذه الحلقه من القدس الون افيتار
المستشار السابق للشؤون العربيه في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه على ان ينضم الينا
ضيوف اخرين في الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه
اذا نبدا معك سيد الون افتار بالنسبه الى
اسرائيل الى اين تتجه الامور بعد التصعيد
الذي حدث بالامس على الجبهات وعوده الهدوء
ولو حذرا في هذه المرحله
المركزي في هذا الوقت
لسياسه المركزيه او الاتجاه الاستراتيجي
تبع اسرائيل هو
عوده او ارجاع الغداء اول شيء وثاني شيء
وس
[موسيقى]
تتحدث تتحدث سيد ايلون عن العمليه في
منطقه الحمراء في الاغوار التي استهدفت
مستوطنتين
وجرحت ثالثه ما الرساله التي فهمتها
اسرائيل من وراء هذه العمليه
العمليات كلها واذيني كمان العمليه اليوم
موجوده حركه حماس
هي مش الجناح العسكري الوحيد اللي بيشتغل
في المنطقه حماس هي الحركه الاسلاميه
الكبيره في
المناطق
انا بحكي على داخل الحدود
وحركه حماس من فتره طويله
تحول من ناحيه التحريض وزياده التحريض في
اسرائيل بين العربي اسرائيل وبين
الفلسطينيين وداخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
دخل حاضمي شريف والى كل البنات هيك الهدف
المركزي تبع حركه حماس مش من اليوم هاي
قبل سنتين
وبطول كمان هو الهدف في الاستراتيجي
الاستراتيجي عفوا
القيادي صلاح
من ناحيته الهدف المركزي تبعها حماس هو
تصعيد واسع وعميق وطويله في كل المناطق بس
موطار غزه
ولكن سيد الون هذا كله يعني الى حد ما هذا
التصعيد الاخير بدا بسبب التصعيد
الاسرائيلي والتضييق على المصلين في داخل
المسجد الاقصى والعلكه شاهدت صور الهجوم
على المصلين في داخل المسجد الاقصى خلال
الايام الماضيه هل اسرائيل مستعده لوقف
هذه الممارسات حتى ربما يتوقف الرد عليها
من جانب هذه الفصائل
المهم عشان لازم نذكر المشاهدين شو صار
خلال الاسبوعين الاخيره خلال اخر اسبوعين
غير
اليوم الاخيره ويومين
كل
خلينا نقول مواصفات وكل المثالين في اللي
دخلوا المسجد الاقصى المبارك صلوا لغبهم
بدون اي مشكله وكل الحريه تدين
كانت بشكل كامل
بس بدون اي مشاكل بدون اي اشكاليات بدون
اي عنف بس قبل يومين مئات من المرسلين
دخلوا للمسجد وكانوا مسلحين كل واحد اخذ
معه حديد احد معه حجر وهو الى اخره
هم انه كرروا لحالهم انه بدهم يكونوا
مسلحين من اجل
من كان مسلحا هم
الاسرائيليون الذين كانوا متواجدين في
داخل ازقه القدس القديمه على اي حال انا
اسالك عن الممارسات الاسرائيليه بحق
المصلين وكلنا شاهدنا كيف دخل جيش
الاسرائيلي الى داخل المسجد الاقصى
واخرج المصلين عنوه من هناك وهذا ما ادى
الى التصعيد هل اسرائيل مستعده لوقف هذه
الممارسات
عندما اكون سعيد جدا تعطيني الفوسه كامل
جمعه
بالحقيقه اذا بدنا نرتب كل الافلام اللي
طلعوا من
كل من كل القنوات ومحطات التلفزيونات
اسرائيل نشرات كل الافلام في الوسائل في
كل ويب سايت اذا بدنا نرتب كل شيء نلغي كل
شيء هيا جزء من
الحريه طيب ممكن نلغيها بس اذا بدنا نوصل
الى الحقيقه نحن بنشوفه انه 300
من المسجد كانوا مسرحين بحديد
لم يكونوا مسلحين ابدا
في الشهادات في اثبات كل شايفين اليوم في
المسجد بعد عيد اعود اعود الى نفس السؤال
هم لم يكونوا مسلحين سيد الون وهذا مثبت
سيد الون اعود الى نفس السؤال بلا هذا
مثبت بلا هذا مثبت لو سمحت اعود الى نفس
السؤال هل هل الجيش الاسرائيلي مستعد لوقف
التصعيد بحق المصلين
وملاحقتهم في داخل المسجد الاقصى لوقف هذا
التصعيد على الجبهات نعم ام لا
انا سعيد كمان مره على سؤالك اول شيء هذا
مش الجيش الاسرائيليه هي المسؤوله هناك
ثاني شيء ثاني شيء
اذا في الجزيره انتم تعطوه للمشاهدينكم كل
الافلام هذا يكون جزء
من انك مصر على هذا الموضوع شكرا لك سيد
الوان
شكرا لك لان الموضوع يعني ما تقوله غير
صحيح اعود واكرر من القدس الون افتار
المستشار السابق للشؤون العربيه في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه نرحب الان بضيفينا من
غزه معنا حسن لافي الكاتب والباحث في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن يجري معنا
الى مفاوضات السلام بالشرق الاوسط مرحبا
بكم ما سنبدا معك سيد حسن لافي باعتقادك
هل انتهت الامور عند هذه النقطه التي وصلت
اليها
لا اعتقد ان الامور انتهت السؤال المركزي
هل ستتراجع اسرائيل عن ممارسات التهويديه
واقتحاماتها
والاعتداءات على المصلين في المسجد الاقصى
في في الشهر الاكثر حرمه لدى المسلمين وهو
في شهر رمضان هنا هنا بدات الحكايه هنا
اساس القضيه القضيه ليست صواريخ اطلقت من
غزه او صواريخ اطبقت من لبنان او عمليه
نفذت فدائيه في الاغوار هذه هي تداعيات ما
يحدث اسرائيل تتناسى عمدا ان المسجد
الاقصى رمزيه اسلاميه وعربيه
لديها حظه كبيره في قلوب المسلمين جميعا
وليس الفلسطينيين وهذه الصور البشعه التي
صدرت في شهر رمضان الذي يكون اكثر قربا
الى الله عز وجل
واعتداءات فاجعه على المصلين بالتاكيد
ستتلقى ضربات ويكون هناك ردات فعل وهذه
الرد الفعل بالمناسبه اسرائيل تدركها ومنذ
اكثر من شهرين واسرائيل تعد العده لهذا
الشهر كثفت اعتقالاتها واغتيلاتها في
الضفه الغربيه بحال من الاحوال من اجل ان
يكون رد الضفه الغربيه ضعيف حاولت ان تكون
غزه مزيدا من التسهيلات والاحتواءات من
اجل مانع غزه من الدخول الى المعركه بمعنى
اخر اسرائيل كانت تعد العده الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الذي يقودها ليس بنيامين
نتنياهو ولكن
يقولون ليلا ونهارا ان الهدف الرئيسي لهذه
الحكومه هو فرض السياده على المسجد الاقصى
السياده اليهوديه وبالتالي القضيه هناك
اذا اذا تراجعت اسرائيل اذا تراجعت
اسرائيل عن ما يخطط له من اقتحامات كبيره
في عيد الفصح والاعياد اليهوديه التي
تلوها تتلاها بالتاكيد سيكون هناك نوع من
انواع الهدوء هذا على المستوى الفلسطيني
على المستوى الاسرائيلي انا اعتقد على
الاسرائيلي كيف نفهم حديث المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان انه لا يريد تصعيدا
ان اسرائيل ستكتفي
بهذا الرد على الرد انجاز التعبير الذي
حدث بالامس وانتهت الامور هنا هل بالفعل
انتهت بالنسبه لاسرائيل الامور عند هذه
النقطه
هذه هذا خديعه كبرى
جميعنا الذكر في عام 2021 استخدم الناطق
الرسمي باسم الجيش والنطق الرسمي الحكومه
في عمليه تضليل كبرى للاعلام الاجنبي من
اجل تنفيذ عمليه ما سميت ايامها بمترو
الانفاق لضرب المقاومه الفلسطينيه في شمال
قطاع غزه بمعنى ان انا اعتقد هذه
التصريحات في سياق امرين الاول ان
الحسابات الاسرائيليه الان لا تريد تصعيدا
في هذه الفتره خلال الايام المقبله لكي
تمر فتره الاعياد ايضا لكي تصبح اسرائيل
لديها المبادره والمبادره في الضربه
الاولى كما حدث في عام 2022 في معركه وحده
الساحات وهذا من اهم الاستخلاصات العبر
والامر الثالث الحسابات المعقده داخل داخل
الحلبه السياسيه على سواء على المستوى
الاقليمي او حتى على المستوى الدولي وكلنا
نعلم ان هناك نوع من انواع النشاز ما بين
المستوى الاقليمي والدولي مع هذه الحكومه
اسرائيل وبالتالي الذهاب الى معركه في هذا
التوقيت سيكون اشكاليه ولكن
بالتفاصيل اسرائيل تلقت كبيره بالامسواء
من الساحل الفلسطيني او من الساحل
اللبنانيه جعلت انها مجبره للذهاب الى
معركه تحت عنوان اعاده قوه الردع
الاسرائيليه بالامس عندما يتم اطلاق
صواريخ 38
صاروخا من الجبهه اللبنانيه سواء كان
اطلاقها فلسطينيا او لبنانيا اذا هناك شخص
قرر ان يذهب الى هذه المواجهه لا يكترث
بقوه الردع الاسرائيليه ولا يكترث
بالتداعيات والامر الاخر في قطعه غزه
الامس سجلت المقاومه الفلسطينيه شيئا
جديدا بالمناسبه وهو مع كل مع كل قصف
اسرائيلي لقطاع كانت تخرج رشقات صاروخيه
بمعنى ان هناك نوع من انواع
فرض معادلات جديده وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد
ان هذا الكلام يصوب في الا في في مصلحه
الخداع الاسرائيلي انتظار اللحظه المهمه
وخاصه مع تصريح بنيامين نتنياهو عندما قال
انتظرهم ايام صعبه لسكان منطقه غلاف غزه
بالفعل
كيف تراقب الولايات المتحده كل هذا المشهد
كما هو الحال دائما فان الولايات المتحده
تحاول ان تبين لكلا طرفين انه من مصلحتهما
ان يتراجع عن ويبتعد عن الصراع المسلح لان
التاريخ علمنا ان تبادل اطلاق الصواريخ من
غزه وايضا
[موسيقى]
محاوله الاسرائيليين اخراج المصلين
المسلمين ليس بمصلحه سكاني
قطاع غزه وهو مثير للقلق للاسرائيليين
ايضا الاخبار الساره حقيقه وهذا مفاجاه
بحد ذاتها انه لم يكن هناك خسائر في
الارواح نتيجه لتبادل لاطلاق الصواريخ
والقنابل في غزه وفي لبنان هذا امر
مفاجئ لكنه مرحب به اعتقد ان الرساله من
المتحده دعونا نحافظ على الامور كما هي
عليه الان
اعتقد ذرات المتحده تمتلك القوه المستقله
لكي تمنع اي طرف من الطرفين ان يتصرف وفقا
لما يراه انه دفاع عن النفس يعني ذكرت
موضوع المسجد الاقصى
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على المصلين في
داخل المسجد الاقصى هل من يعني هل هو كافن
بنظر الاداره الامريكيه ان تتم ادانه هذه
الممارسات ان يتم القول انه يجب الحفاظ
على الوضع الراهن في الاماكن المقدسه من
دون اجبار السلطات الاسرائيليه على وقف
هذه الممارسات التي يقول الفلسطينيون انها
تهدف فعليا الى تغيير الوضع القائم في
المسجد الاقصى
من الواضح ان كلا الطرفين حتى لا يتفقان
على الجوانب الاكثر اساسيه هناك في حماس
من ينظر الى خارطه الشرق الاوسط ولا يرى
فيها وجودا لاسرائيل والان نرى ان بعض
اركان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ينظر الى خريطه
الشرق الاوسط ولا يرى فيها فلسطين وطالما
استمر الوضع على هذا هذه الحال وهؤلاء
كانوا من من يقرر المستقبل لا يبدو مضيئا
او مشرقا لكن الاخبار الساره ايضا ان هناك
مصلين عادوا الى المسجد الاقصى فالامر لا
يبدو وكان اسرائيل تحاول ابعاد المصلين
الى الابد وبشكل دائم وكما سمعتم من من
ضيفكم السابق حتى لم يتفق معكم هل كان
المصلون مسلحين هل كان يحملون عصي او
حجاره طبعا حتى هو يقصد مسلحين ويتحدث عن
حجاره وهناك اذا فارق كبير في مواقف
الطرفين يعني لتوضيح هذه النقطه وما حدث
مع الضيف الاسرائيلي هو يحاول ان يصور ان
المصلين الذين يدخلون الى داخل المسجد
الاقصى كانوا يحملون اسلحه بينما كل
الانباء المثبته تؤكد انهم لم يحملوا اي
سلاح وهناك اصلا تضييق على المصلين للوصول
الى داخل باحات المسجد الاقصى ولعل ضيفنا
السيد حسن لافي من غزه يمكن ان يشرح لنا
اكثر هذا الموضوع لان اسرائيل تحاول ان
تقول انظروا هناك حريه عباده المصلين
يستطيعون الوصول الى داخل المسجد الاقصى
ما حقيقه الوضع سيد حسن
اختي الكريمه هذه خدعه كبيره تحاول
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تسويقها تحت شعار
يعني مهم وكبير اسمه حريه العباده اي حريه
عباده المسجد هو حريه عباده للمسلمين ليس
المسجد الاقصى منذ احتلال اسرائيل لعام 67
هناك اتفاقيات ما تسمى اتفاقيات الوضع
الراين ما بين اسرائيل والمملكه الاردنيه
وبين اسرائيل والوقف الاسلامي الذي يدير
هذه العمليات عمليه اداره المسجد الاقصى
اي حريه اديان هل مسموح بمثل الان
للمسلمين ان يذهبوا الى الفاتيكان ويطلب
ان يصلوا في في عيد وقداس المسيحيين
ويزاحمونهم في الفاتيكان هذا ليس ليس حريه
عباده الحقيقه ان هناك هدف استراتيجي
للحركه الصهيونيه ودوله الاحتلال اسمه
تهويد مدينه القدس
وفصل المسجد الاقصى
وهدموا حتى وصولا الى بناء ما يسمى
بالهيكل وجمعيات اعاده بناء الهيكل
المدعومه الان من من تيار قوي داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اعلنت انه في يوم
الاربعاء الماضي في اول ايام عيد الفصح
العبري انها تريد ذبح القرابين بالنسبه
للمصلين بالمناسبه كل فلسطيني ياتي الى
القدس يدخل من عده بوابات بدايه من دخول
مدينه القدس وصولها الى باب العمود
واجراءات وتفتيشات بشكل كبير على قبل ان
يصل الى باب المسجد الاقصى هناك تفتيش
يدوي وتفتيش الكتروني يمنع منعا باتا
الدخول ولاحظنا في الشاشات عندما خرج
المصلين كيف كان هناك طابورين من الجنود
تعتدي على المصلين الحجاره الذي تكلم عنها
هذه حجاره المسجد الاقصى
ما بيد الفلسطيني الا حجاره هذا المسجد
ليدافع عنه اذا هذه مخادعه كبيره حريه انا
لو ممكن بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي
الاسرائيلي متغطي بالموقف الامريكي وخاصه
موقف الاداره بخاصه موقف دونالد ترامب
الاداره السابقه عندما نقلت السفاره
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه الى الى القدس
واعلنت ان القدس عاصمه يهوديه عاصمه
اليهود هذا الكلام اعطى كثيرا من الثقه
بالذات للمتطرفين
وغيرهما لتغيير الوضع الراهن في القدس
وبالتالي امريكا تتحمل بجزء اساسي من عدم
استقرار المنطقه الذي لا يصب للمصلحه
الامريكيه في هذا الوقت الحالي اشكرك من
غزه حسن لا في الكاتب والبحث في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه وشكرا للسيد ريتش الرئيس
السابق بالكلانتن الى مفاوضات السلام
بالشرق الاوسط ضيفنا من نيوجيرسي للاسف
هذا كل ما يتيح لنا الوقت في هذه الحلقه
اذا الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]